my next guest knows all too well what
it's like to work for the royal
household he is the former royal Butler
to His Royal Highness Prince Charles and
Camilla the Duchess of Cornwall please
welcome mr. grant Harold y'all first met
Prince Charles and Camilla it was it was
quite nerve-racking in fact I wasn't
sure what the what the protocol was what
you're supposed to do what you're not
supposed to do and the confession I have
to make is that I was in Scotland
there's this long corridor and they
appeared at the end of the corridor and
I panicked and I remember thinking what
do you do what can you speak to them can
you do not speak to them and there was a
there was a door on the right-hand side
so I thought I went to this room and
I'll keep Italy for a minute - until you
were past unfortunately it wasn't a room
it was a storage cupboard yes there was
actually glass and bottles and so I
thought they're gonna think I'm a
alcoholic yeah exactly and I canna stood
there next ahead with the pins gun do
you think he's okay I'm there I thought
right I better I better okay I opened
the door and I tried to be very
professional and I didn't make eye
contact and there was a door on the
other side so I opened the door on the
other side praying
it was another cupboard and it was a
staircase and I remember kanigan ah the
staircase and then I looked to mean good
morning Royal Highnesses I think carried
on and luckily they started laughing you
gave me a lot of crap man I'm just
saying grant okay but how did we do
today silver we have silver so this is
what we felt this is great and you've
got a silver is a silver teaspoon yeah
don't say though I know that y'all don't
like bags right you like loosely because
I know two bags of it yeah no okay
posh party about and you've got the
lemon which is Finn I mean I've got to
watch because I'm sitting next to
country-western royalties I've got to
kind of make sure I do the
but we've got the lemons so if it's a
narrow gray I assume this is a degree Oh
fantastic would you like to try it
Oh have you would you I've already yeah
I've would you like to I will take some
you want me to is that okay we haven't
changed in a huff wait no I'm totally
gonna tell everyone that you like did
this for royalty and than me oh I do
what some someone no I like it playing
okay [ __ ]
oh no don't I love you sure you love
lemon you should maybe like I mean let's
just get sugar while we're at it we're
growing it's sugar sugar no no what no
why is it they're a mess occasion I
wouldn't not with it yeah just one more
little thing have you got you're not
gonna have you know I'm very fancy grant
we need we need we need today I'm
bringing the class grant oh yes I can
tell we're gonna do is um you're gonna
do a very gentle back and forward motion
yeah no what you don't you don't do
because we're not in a band away and
then you place it on the side okay so
how would you do this bear how would you
okay how would I pick it up how would
you pick the cut part oh well by the tea
thing
are you kidding I'm just like getting
ready to dance
[Applause]
so you you may you may need yeah sure
keep that and I I'm never gonna make it
as a royal it's over no it's fine but I
didn't notice you cannot seem to kind of
pick it with two hands no please just to
reassure you nobody's gonna steal it
from me dear so no one you ain't where
I'm from well so what you do is you pick
up the whole thing together okay and
then we pick up with the handle we don't
stick the pinkies out we're not testing
the way are you thirsty at this point
I've got my pinkie no no pinkie sense
you're not test and yet we're not
testing the wind do it yeah doing the
way the forecast that's a myth yeah
absolutely it's a mess Holly why just so
we can you know hello everybody it's
yeah they're in the drink when we drink
what we don't do we don't go well you
don't do that oh we do it very very
don'ts know none of us is very gentle
lady hmm are you doing like Hawaii it's
delicious it's slightly cold so that
that's gonna how you how you do it and
you'd have some sandwiches and I noticed
those square sandwiches yeah yes that
was lovely I am going to invite you to
my barn and we're gonna have tea there
baden we do a barn oh wait I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop
yep still here not going anywhere I see
you don't walk away from this